I'm mr. Wu and my channel is all about  learning I love doing it and I love  helping others to do it too I guess  that's why I became a teacher every day  when I walk into my classroom I set up  my camera I turn on my microphone and I  record my lessons it's real teaching  real people and my hope is that it's  real learning for everyone who watches  whether you're in the room with me or  halfway across the other side of the  world so if you want to learn about  mathematics or the way the technology  works or pick up a musical instrument or  if you just want to understand life in  general and I hope you'll join me and we  can learn together  [Music]